so the major story that dropped
yesterday and just let's just see how
the corporate media covers or does not
cover this one is that in essence the
FBI and the CIA have been working with
big Tech we all kind of suspected it but
yeah it turns out that it's true we've
got some info from Breitbart here
Executives from Facebook and Twitter
including the recently fired head of
trust and safety vijayagade that was the
woman who was just fired from Twitter
held regular meetings with the
Department of Homeland Security to
discuss censorship on a wide range of
topics including the withdrawal from
Afghanistan coronavirus and racial
Justice according to leaked documents
the information came to light via leaks
to The Intercept as well as documents
and minutes revealed through Missouri
Attorney General Eric Schmidt's lawsuit
filed against the Biden Administration
that alleges government collusion with
big Tech to suppress America's first
right First Amendment rights the report
also reveals
an official process for the government
to flag misinformation to Facebook via
The Intercept there is also a formalized
process for government officials to
directly flag content on Facebook or
Instagram and request that it be
throttled or suspended through a special
Facebook portal that requires a
government or law enforcement email to
use at the time of writing the content
request system at facebook.com X
takedowns slash login is still live DHS
Department of Homeland Security and meta
the parent company of Facebook did not
respond to a request for comment the FBI
declined to comment some of the meetings
between social media representatives and
the government included Kate starberg
the leftist professor who leads the
election Integrity partnership in June
the same DHS advisory committee of sisa
which includes Twitter head of legal
policy trust and safety Vijaya got a and
University of Washington Professor Kate
star drafted a report to the sisa
director calling for an expansive role
for the agency in shaping the
information ecosystem the report called
on the agency to closely monitor social
media platforms of all sizes mainstream
media cable news hyper partisan media
talk radio and other online resources
they argued that the agency needed to
take steps to Halt the spread of false
and misleading information with a focus
on information that undermines key
Democratic institutions such as the
courts or by other sectors such as the
financial system or public health
measures okay guys this is seriously
massive this is not nothing this is big
okay the government was working with big
Tech we all kind of thought it it all
felt very weird why did that Hunter
Biden thing disappear why could people
not only not share the story and the New
York Post a place of Journalism for over
a hundred years was suspended from
Twitter but if you took the link from
their website and shared it in your
private messages on Twitter your direct
messages suddenly it would disappear
why is it that we know obviously some
people are blown off Twitter they're
blown off Twitter like Donald Trump like
project Veritas because they go against
the narrative and it very rarely happens
to lefties the idea that the government
wasn't even just about covet and
elections it was also about people who
were arguing against the narrative
related to Afghanistan I mean this is
deep deep stuff and really think about
it what is the first amendment guys you
all know it I have a bright audience
right this isn't MSNBC over here the
First Amendment means that the
government cannot infringe on your right
to free speech so if you were using your
speech on a platform like Twitter and
the government was coming in and
censoring it Shadow Banning it deleting
it whatever they were doing with it a
government agent was acting and
infringing on your First Amendment right
to free speech this is this is huge